[Musica]
cominciamo da qua cos'è questa questo
valente tutti noi conosciamo la lente
valente cosa serve una lente cismo ci fa
vedere le cose che noi da soli non
riusciamo a vedere ma la magia che
adesso voglio dirvi che in realtà se ci
pensate bene né dentro la parola
lentezza c'è la penna lente c'è la
parola lente come dirci che anche la
lentezza è un dispositivo che ci
aiutarli dire cose che diversamente non
potremo vedere che la velocità non ci
consente di vedere perché la velocità ci
rende il tutto sfuggente tutto continua
a sfuggirci dalle mani alla velocità
cosa interessa la crosta interessa
portarci a destinazione nel più breve
tempo possibile
questa è la sua sessione che è diventata
anche la nostra
anche noi siamo ossessionati dalla
velocità harmon rosa è un filosofo
tedesco ci ha ragionato molto sulla
velocità studi pro meraviglioso si
chiama accelerazione alla nazione e dice
che siamo talmente ossessionati dalla
velocità che la velocità stessa è
diventata norma sociale prevalente è lei
che comanda su di noi
addirittura è diventata qualcosa che è
talmente naturale che la usiamo per
distinguere i vincenti quelli che vanno
veloci dai perdenti quelli che quando
piano
se ci pensate proprio così quando un
paese in crisi quando il nostro paese in
crisi cosa fa cosa ci propone ci propone
di investire nella velocità i suoi
simboli sono le strade l'autostrada e
gli aeroporti l'alta velocità sono tutta
questa grammatica che ci viene proposta
come la ricetta del benessere ma siamo
sicuri che ne possiamo fare a meno della
lentezza sono sicuri che possiamo
trascurarla torniamo un passo indietro
andiamo alla pandemia nella padania
siamo stati bloccati in casa abbiamo
sognato di evadere
ma tra le cose che sognavamo sognavamo
una passeggiata quando ci hanno chiuso i
parchi noi sognavamo di andarci di
passeggiare da tichy cinque minuti
abbiamo visto le città che spogliate
dalla velocità tolta la velocità dalle
dalle città sono diventati silenziose
sono diventate più belle sono diventate
le acque dei fiumi sono diventate più
chiare
l'aria più respirabile abbiamo piano
piano capito intuito che quella roba lì
era un bisogno fondamentale non possiamo
farne a meno
cerchiamo di capire bene il protagonista
della nostra vicenda la lentezza cos'e
una cosa l'abbiamo già detta con la
lente la lentezza ci fa vedere meglio le
cose quando noi passiamo accanto degli
alberi non sono più alberi sono platani
tigli pini abeti il paesaggio lo vedete
qua quando andiamo veloci paesaggio si
svuota
abbiamo dei contorni indefiniti abbiamo
delle chiazze di colore verde marrone
grigio non più di questo quando invece
noi rallentiamo il paesaggio si riempì
torno essere vivo si riempì di
particolari le case non sono tutti
uguali
sono tutte diverse i profili sono
continui milan kundera dice una cosa
meravigliosa
per il momento in cui noi distinguiamo i
paesaggi nel momento in cui noi vediamo
le differenze la nostra testa analizza e
memorizza è infatti leggete la lentezza
è direttamente proporzionale
all'intensità della memoria la velocità
per contro è direttamente proporzionale
all'intensità dell'oblio
non riusciamo a ricordare noi andando
veloce allora questo ci si dice un'altra
cosa ci dice che alla fine la lentezza
tra i tanti benefici che cita è anche
una strategia per apprendere capire dove
siamo capire che siamo
mi viene da dire che la lentezza e cura
e sapete perché perché la parola cura
un'altra parola meravigliosa la sua
radice kukua la sua antica radice e quel
kukua vuol dire osservare e torna la
lente torna la lente quindi vedete
lentezza osservare prendersi cura non
finisce qui torniamo alla velocità la
velocità ci condiziona ci assorbe ci
prende
e la lentezza ci libera ci vede anche
più padroni del tempo e oggi ne abbiamo
bisogno di tornare a essere padrone del
tempo di non essere dietro le notifiche
nei nostri smartphone per esempio quando
noi guidiamo l'auto velocemente e l'auto
che decide come cosa dobbiamo fare
i nostri gradi di libertà si comprimono
dobbiamo curvare dobbiamo accelerare
dobbiamo superare dobbiamo obbedire a
quella roba lì ha lentamente quando noi
andiamo lentamente
noi torniamo a decidere cosa fare
torniamo a gustare il nostro tempo
altra cosa la lentezza riflettevo è per
tutti tutti possono accedere alla
lentezza ma non tutti alla velocità men
che meno se alta perché la velocità un
costo costa la velocità è più alta più
costa e più costa meno persone possono
accedervi
allora vedete quante cose quanti
benefici ci può darlo lentezza tempo
bellezza equità paesaggio possiamo farne
a meno davvero può una società solamente
investire in velocità no
allora vediamo di capire però questa
intensa dove la mettiamo perché nella
stanza bloccati dalla pandemia quella
non la volevamo allora se proviamo a
fare un altro passaggio e facciamoci
aiutare da un antropologo team in gold
tv gold ha dedicato tutto
la sua vita a studiare la linea adesso
ne prendiamo la lentezza da depositiamo
sulla linea scopriamo delle cose
meravigliose perché la linea
se ci pensate tutto il nostro mondo una
linea perché cantare camminare guardare
raccontare storia storie disegnare
scrivere tutto procede per linee la
musica ha bisogno della linea ha bisogno
del pentagramma la chitarra bisogno
delle corde la nostra scrittura una
linea le pagine di un libro sono righe
tutto linea tutto il mondo e linea e in
particolare a noi interessano le linee
che sono sentieri le linee che sono c
ciclabili perché lì dentro si innesca
quell andamento lento che comincia a
essere piccola magia lentezza e linea
cominciano a vivere in simbiosi non solo
la linea è stata anche molto importante
nella storia dell'uomo perché e ci aiuta
la francesco careri è stato il primo
atto in cui l'uomo ha come dire
disegnato il suo territorio il suo
paesaggio francesco karrer e ciò
spiegabilissimo con questa frase il
primo atto creativo dell'uomo sul
paesaggio è stato un sentiero quel
sentiero che lo conduceva dal suo
rifugio
probabilmente al primo albero da frutta
ma vedete che roba incredibile lentezza
linea meravigliose intuizione terzo
protagonista della nostra del nostro
racconto
se prendiamo come di e l'inter se li nea
e cominciamo a lavorarci per giorni e
giorni
viaggiamo ci mettiamo movimento
viaggiamo lentamente viaggio lento il
viaggio lento come dire qualcosa di
molto importante con la lentezza e la
linea
perché è qualcosa che i sit etica
completamente al tempo del durante
quello che accade tra l'origine a
destinazione quello che accade durante i
miei passi nella linea e straordinaria
questa cosa e ci consente di immaginare
delle scoperte semplicissime viaggiando
chi di noi ha camminato chi di noi ha
pedalato una giornata assolata
a un certo punto passato nell'ombra di
un bosco sarà accolta immediatamente
della frescura è in quel momento che tu
capisci uno dei benefici del bosco
lentamente viaggiando su una linea eco
si osservi un muretto a secco e i tuoi
occhi seguono la fila dei mattoni e così
sento il profumo del pane
tutto questo è scoperta tutto questo e
poesia
tutto questo è un cedere il passo alla
bellezza ma che avviene con la lentezza
perché diversamente tutte queste cose
che io appena vi ho raccontato con la
velocità le salti perché se è
ossessionato dalla destinazione come lo
sono i turismi della destinazione la
destinazione turistica quarto
protagonista
ora mettiamo insieme tutto viaggio linea
lentezza di cosa ne viene fuori
tiri fuori quello che noi chiamiamo
progetto i territori viene fuori un'idea
pd fuori un grande progetto di
rigenerazione viene fuori qualcosa che è
una visione è qualcosa che una ricetta
per i nostri territori un lavoro per
mettere insieme centro e periferia
un lavoro per ridare protagonismo a quei
paesaggi che sono dimenticati che sono
come dicevamo prima saltati dalla
velocità
ora se non vogliamo cadere nella
trappola di ridurre un paese appunti le
città d'arte non esistono le città
d'arte
esiste un paese che è tutto è arte e
proprio
questo paese d'arte molecolare diffusa
dell'asta intercettato con queste linee
l'ente che capillarmente delicatamente
entrano in questi paesaggi l'italia
bella dentro dice un libro molto bello
il titolo di un libro di luca martinelli
ed è vero è vero perché queste linee
possono andare a ricucire questa
bellezza diffusa in cui noi
rispecchiando ci scopriamo di nuovo chi
siamo e ci piace pensare che tutto
questo
tutta questa visione questa cosa che noi
abbiamo chiamato progetto di territorio
sia una sfida e non sia uno svantaggio
al in terza non è uno svantaggio non è
il marchio di fabbrica dei perdenti
no se pensiamo tutte le cose che abbiamo
detto e abbiamo deciso che non possiamo
farne a meno pure oggi possiamo dire con
fierezza che la lentezza è un diritto e
noi abbiamo bisogno di un piano per
crescere rallentando abbiamo bisogno io
credo che questa cosa noi possiamo
chiamarla progetto paese
abbiamo diritto la lentezza abbiamo
diritto a una lentezza che non si può
affidare un caso non avviene per caso ma
deve avvenire progettando la progettando
la lentezza si avventasse un diritto io
credo che possiamo dire altrettanto che
deve diventare la base di quel progetto
paese che dicevo prima
perché se un paese investe incammini in
ciclabili e sono molto convinto che
investe infelicità investe lentezza
perché la lentezza ci dà felicità e la
dà a tutti grazie
[Musica]